look I really hate it that y'all have
had to put a little bit of a Hiatus on
the tour you got to push pause uh for at
least about six weeks now so what's the
latest how are you pivoting have you
talked to Morgan how's he doing I've
talked to him he's he's doing fine I
know he's just laying low and protecting
his voice
um
you know selfishly and thankfully it
only affected a few shows of mine so
we're some of those like uh we're kind
of doing our own thing anyway and and we
might make something up or or fill in
the gaps but if not we'll just take a
little bit of time off and get back in
July
make sure he's doing that vocal rest
because a lot of fans want to see him
back in action
[Music]
[Applause]
you want me to hold everything mister I
mean you can hold out as heavy as hell
it sure is I love it I'll just bye y'all
I'm kidding how good does it feel to be
winning one of these tonight it's cool
it's really cool
um
just especially for the song you know uh
it means a lot and I've always cared a
lot about the song and what it stands
for and I know it can be kind of
controversial but I'm just glad that we
kind of not even kinda but we have the
back of country music in the industry to
vote for a song and yeah it's it's cool
I feel like a song like that is that's
the foundation of what country music was
built on so I'm glad that we're keeping
that alive dude you are doing it and you
are doing it well you are one heck of a
songwriter and proof is in the pudding
because you this is not the only award
that you've taken home yeah yeah we got
a couple of other ones I mean yeah
you make room hey how's married life
treating you these days it's great I got
I got a good one so she makes it really
easy I mean y'all's wedding looked like
the party of the year it was it was last
year wasn't it yeah it was in October it
was uh
it was the worst hangover I've ever had
the next day well honey if there's not
even kidding
good party
responsible for that hanging
buddy of yours I mean me it was
definitely just me I don't know uh man
Cali I mean Cali she can bring out the
party in me but we had a great time but
it was it was a rough day after that but
we just laid in bed all day it was a
good day it's rainy it was perfect oh
that's so good that performance is
pretty perfect up there oh thank you
that song Is My Jam thank you
[Music]
out of the truck there this morning
it's so good he's got a little rock and
roll the metal and yellow country
Jack just went number one too right yeah
yeah yeah uh two or three weeks ago all
right where's that bad boy going I don't
know I gotta uh we we got a mantle that
that has nothing on it but a uh a little
Roku uh Receiver right now so we might
line up your game with some cowboy hats
brother
thank you